so hello everybody and welcome to yet
another episode of biographics I'm your
interim host Carl Smallwood yes that is
my real name and today we're talking
about Dutch Schulz the Beer Baron of the
Bronx and before we get to the topic of
today's video I should apologize I have
a cold so yeah my voice is going to be
more annoying than usual for the people
in the comments leaving those hurtful
messages about the way I talk so I'm
trying but if I don't work I don't get
paid and I like affording food rent and
uh clothing so let's get to
it beer Bloodshed and buried treasure
that is the Legacy left behind by one of
New York's most notorious malactor
mobsters and Bootleggers Dutch Schultz
like many of the criminals of his era
Schultz saw prohibition as not a law to
be followed but a golden ticket to a
life full of riches and power and he was
right although many people did have to
die for him to achieve his goals he
fought not one but two bloody gang wars
in order to firmly establish himself as
New York's Premier distributor of
illegal Hooch the cause of and solution
to all of life's problems to alcohol
before we continue I'd like to pull back
the curtain on the production of these
videos a little bit to tell you guys
about something the authors of scripts
like to do sometimes that is leave
little comments in their scripts that
provide things like pronunciation guides
sometimes they'll put jokes in there and
other times they'll add little addendums
to provide text for certain parts of the
script what the author of today's script
has done is they just includ a little
dend them saying this is a Simpsons
reference and as a pro it you don't need
to do that if the very first thing I
thought of when I saw the title of this
script was oh home Simpson the Beer
Baron episode let's go and I was going
to make Beer Baron references all the
way through this thing well that's just
very cute and I appreciate that thank
you to the author let's move on
so the early years
Dutch Schultz was born Arthur Simon
flegenheimer on August 6th 1902 in the
Bronx to a couple of German Jewish
immigrants named Herman and Emma
flegenheimer he adopted the name Dutch
Schultz and was also sometimes known as
simply the Dutchman pretty early on in
his criminal career and we're going to
stick with that from the beginning to
make it less confusing presumably schz
concluded quite reasonably we think that
nobody would be intimidated by somebody
called Arthur flegenheimer I mean the
fenhe a gang doesn't really strike fear
into the hearts of men and I say that as
a small word I'm reminded of my mom who
is called um I'm not going to say her
first name but her last name is
Smallwood and uh she is currently
engaged to be married to a man with the
last name Woodcock this is not a joke
you've got great taste in men great Emma
flegenheimer tried to instill a devout
and modest upbringing into her son but
it was no use growing up on the Mean
Streets of the Bronx young Dutch
frequently go into scrap with other kids
and eventually joined a gang for aded
protection and to look cool and it
probably won't be much of a surprise to
you to find out that he didn't really
care much for school and here's a bonus
fact for you trivia Buffs out there the
principal of schz of school was Dr John
fondan who would later attain infation
during the lyberg baby case as he was
the one who delivered the $50,000 Ransom
to the kidnappers only to be later
double cross but that's a story for
another day now at some point during
dut's childhood his father abandoned the
family we're not really sure when
exactly that was some sources say Dutch
was 14 years old and others claim that
Herman flegenheimer was already gone by
the 1910 census which would make Dutch 8
years or younger and some sources say
that Herman never left at all and died
anyway the Salient Point here is that
the family was left without its bread
winner so Dutch eventually dropped out
of school completely to make himself and
his family some money an honest day's
pay for an honest day's work was never
really on the cards for Schultz but he
thought he'd give it the old College try
he worked a few odd jobs for deciding
that they all left him too poor and too
unhappy to keep going being there
instead he started hanging out at a
local nightclub owned by a two-bit
gangster called Marcel PUO hoping that
he would find some better work there PUO
had a fairly long wrap sheet full of
stickups burglaries bank robberies and
probably some jayw walking too a thing I
can't believe is a crime in America it
was only normal that schz would try to
emulate his new Mentor he began holding
up card games and committing burglaries
but he was still just a green horn at
this whole crime thing so when he was 17
years old he was caught trying to break
into an apartment he was arrested and
sentenced to 17 months in prison and
sent to Roosevelt Island still known as
Blackwell's Island at the time Dutch was
released on parole in December of 1920
but he had no intention of changing his
criminal ways and going straight
especially now that a Golden Goose had
been presented to him that being the
United States Congress passing the
Volstead Act and America entering
prohibition the beer Wars
begin once he was out of prison
Schultz's only concern was was to make
money and lots of it he went back to one
of his old jobs with a trucking company
and was pleasantly surprised to discover
that while he was behind bars they had
decided to turn to the dark side and
become a smuggling operation bringing
booze from Canada he wrode to them for a
while earning a few books here and there
but more importantly making the
connections that he needed with New
York's criminal underworld schz met and
even work with some important gangsters
during this time such as Arnold
Rothstein Lucky Luciano and an Irish
mobster called Jack Legs Diamond but
more on him later because he does play
quite a key role in this story by the
mid 1920s shortz's basic bootlegging
business led to another gig working in a
Speak Easy in the Bronx for an old
childhood friend and up and cominging
gangster himself named Joey Noe the two
of them saw how much money there was to
be made from just selling booze
especially illegal boo so they got their
own little operation off the ground with
no way eventually taking on schs as a
full-time partner at this point do schz
was settling nicely into the deserved
reputation as a violent and bloodthirsty
psychopath that you would not want to to
mess with the kind of guy that will
prove useful to have when you trying to
Strongarm your way into the bootlegging
Market Schultz used his menacing ways to
intimidate rival Saloon owners into
buying beer from them and them
exclusively on occasion even kidnapping
and torturing those who refused to see
eye to eye with him and his business
partner with that kind of reputation it
was only a couple of years until the
dynamic duo became the most prominent
hoop suppliers in all of the Bronx so
naturally they look to expand that
operation into Manhattan but this caused
a problem there was a lot of money on
the line and other people were not going
to give up their slice of the pie so
willingly just because the NOA schz gang
was in town as you might imagine
Manhattan was already pretty well
supplied with intoxicating Spirits so
the Dutchman's arrival briman's conflict
with the aform menion legs diamond and
the Irish mob he did not take long for
this one to get bloody Diamond wanted to
cut the head off the serpent right off
the bat so the first Domino to fall was
none other than Joey NOA himself on the
night of October 15th 1928 noi and Dutch
stopped at the swanny club next to
harland's iconic Apollo Theater The
Hangout was
supposed supposed doing a lot of heavy
lifting here to be safe ground even
between feuding gangsters who wanted
each other dead sort of like the
Continental from John Wick the rule was
that when two rival Mobsters ran into
each other the one who arrived last had
to sit down for just a single drink and
then leave the club was also a popular
hot spot with off duty cops which helped
maintain its neutral status violence
inside the swanny club might have been
off limits but once you're out the door
you were on your own much like the
Continental that night shortz and Noe
stayed and pied until the we hours of
the morning around 7:00 a.m. Joey Noe
finally left the club was making his way
towards his par car when a blue Cadillac
pulled up and two men open fire Noe was
hit multiple times but was thankfully
wearing a bulletproof vest so he did not
collapse immediately instead he pulled
out his own gun return fire at the
getaway vehicle the Cadillac zigzagged
violently and scwi a par car before
disappearing into the night leaving
behind a car door as a souvenir it was
clear that Noe had hit his Target but
his wounds finally got the better of him
and he crumpled to the ground barely
clinging to life later that same night
police found the blue caddy abandoned on
the Lower East Side inside on the back
seat was the dead body of trigger man
Lewis Weinberg who clearly got the worst
of it from the shootout with Joey but
Schultz's partner wasn't exactly in mint
condition himself taken to the Roosevelt
Hospital doctors did manage to stabilize
him for the time being but a recovery
was not on the cards noi lingered around
for another month or so before finally
shuffling off this Mortal coil in
November of 1928 Schulz were was
understandably devastated by the loss of
the one person in his line of work he
can actually call a friend and mean it
but he was consoled by the fact that he
was now the sole boss of their entire
bootlegging Empire Still his issue with
Legs Diamond were far from settled he
has often been claimed although never
substantiated we are talking about the
often murky world of organized crime
here that Schultz had Diamond's
associate and Mentor Arnold Rothstein
killed in retaliation for no's death ens
Ros steam was shot over an unpaid
gambling Deb although there are some who
believe it was the Dutchman who had
ordered the hit either way way it was
clear the gang war would continue until
either Schultz or Diamond was dead
dutcher's problem however is that his
rival was something of a bullet sponge
who simply just refused to die leg
diamond have been shot 14 times on no
less than four separate occasions and he
survived every single time earning him
the additional nickname of quite
fittingly the clay pigeon it's presumed
that at least one if not two of these
assassination attempts happened on
Dutch's orders but Legs Diamond wasn't
exactly the kind of guy to get shot and
tell so we can't really say for sure
eventually though Diamond's look did run
out and on December of 1931 he was in
Albany New York celebrating with friends
his aquit in a kidnapping trial just mob
boss things afterwards he abandoned the
party to meet up with his mistress and
after that encounter was finished he
drunkenly stumbled into his hotel room
and passed out two or more assassins
paid him a visit and this time they took
no chances Diamond was shot three times
in the head from close range and that
was finally enough to put him down for
the count again Schultz was always the
main suspect behind the hit but nothing
concrete ever tied him to the murder
with legs diamond and his gang out of
the way schz had a clear path to
Proclaim himself the Undisputed Beer
Baron of New York except not quite
because as soon as one threat was
eliminated another one emerged and if we
are putting Clips in of this can we put
in my favorite moment of the Beer Baron
episode where like you know I actually
watched it the other day it's just the
guy's like I'll get you Beer Baron and
you just hear from the distance like no
you
won't that always craped me up
the Beer Baron vers the Mad dub the gang
war between Schultz and Diamond left
quite a few bodies in its W but as it
turned out this was just the appetizer
to the main course that was about to be
Unleashed on the streets of New York
this time it was one of shortz's own
Associates who decided to try and shoot
his way to the top an Irish Hitman by
the name Vincent madog Cole Cole was the
type of guy who made shorts who remember
we described as being a psychopath
looked like a level-headed and tranquil
individual Cole had a very very itchy
trigger finger and would shoot at the
slightest provocation and he really
didn't care who was in his way in fact
his most notorious moment came when he
mercilessly gunned down a 5-year-old
child during a failed kidnapping the boy
wasn't the intended target he was just
an innocent bystander who had The
Misfortune of Being in the wrong place
at the wrong time that wrong place and
time being anywhere near Co the killer
was arrested but he got off scotf free
due to a lack of evidence and a
problematic witness however from that
day on he became known as The Mad Dog
and the baby killer the former being the
nickname he decides to keep because you
know baby killer isn't exactly going to
actually he's probably going to inspire
fear but not a lot of respect initially
shorts make good use of the Mad Dog's
talents the latter became one of the
Dutchman's Main enforcers and often paid
visits to Bar owners who refused to sell
his booze in 1927 he was even put on
trial for the murder of a Speak Easy
owner but was acquitted thanks some jury
interference from his boss but Cole got
too big for his britches pretty fast
feeling Invincible as he want to happen
when you going to shoot people with
impunity he started doing off the book
jobs without Dutch's permission such as
robberies and kidnappings and when schz
confronted him not only did Cole not
apologize but then double down and
demanded to be made a partner after all
Joey no way wasn't around anymore so who
better than the Mad Dog unsurprisingly
Schultz turned down Call's offer as
tempting as it must have been but now we
had a problem since it was clear that
Cole wasn't the type of guy who would
take the rejection lying down his
moniker was very fitting since Dutch
felt like he had a Mad Dog on the loose
and he had to put it down but Cole had
been busy forming his own little gang
and was ready to go to war against the
Dutch criminal Empire now it's hard to
say exactly how many people died as a
direct result of this conflict which
lasted two years between 1930 and 1932
because at the time New York City was
something of a war zone is also dealing
with a mafia War which was called the
castom marass which I hope I'm
pronouncing correctly and probably not
I'm sorry between Mafia factions but if
you want to find out more about that one
you can check out our other multiple
videos some of which are presented by me
on Italian Mobsters because we've
covered that ground several times before
some have reported that colon his crew
killed around 20 of shortz's men though
the Dutchman himself was careful to
never get caught in the crossfire he
even cut down on his own drinking during
this period to have his wits about him
more again I'll make a reference to The
Simpsons prohibition episode of like
prohibition was great people were
drinking more partying but without
alcohol prohibition kind of sucks so the
way Cole was going through the
opposition like a hot knife through
butter he may have emerged triumphant
and become the new be a baron if not for
his own hu bris and a forementioned
sense of invincibility taking on Dutch
schz was bad enough but what if he
decided to also make enemies of the
mafia and the Irish mob well that's
exactly what Cole did living up to his
Monica of the madg as we said he had no
quals about taking any job as long as
the pay was good and he didn't care who
the target was even if the target was
say a mob boss unsurprisingly it's
approach to life doesn't earn you a lot
of friends but does make you a lot of
enemies and he made enemies of the Irish
go for gang when he kidnapped for ransom
a close associate of the gang's leader
Oni Madden he also then doubled down on
how screwed he was by pissing off the
mafia when he accepted a hit on Lucky
Luciano on behalf of his boss SL enemy
salvator Marzano but Luciano found out
about it and ordered a faster more
efficient and successful hit on Marzano
and by their time Cole was ready to
strike his employer was already dead
Luciano was now the new head of the
mafia and was very aware that Cole was
going to try and kill him it said that
there was a point when Schultz Madden
and Luciano had all put out a price on
Vincent Cole's head at the same time
resulting in basically every criminal in
New York with a gun going after him Cole
was basically John Wick without the dead
dog the badass Factor the coolness
factor of like you know being Keo Reeves
or just any of the Charisma that he
displayed due to the whole killing a
child thing so he wasn't really like
John Wick but with that kind of heat on
him his demise would be inevitable as
much as it would be bloody on February
1st 1932 four gunman working for Schultz
or Madden we don't know for sure burst
in on a card game in progress in the
north Bronx that call was supposed to
attend an open fire indiscriminately on
all six people in that room killing
three and wounding the rest but still
not getting call because he' not arrived
yet and just something that always
strikes me as surprising which I ended
up doing independent research on is it's
really hard to kill somebody with a gun
like obviously it's guns kill people a
lot but so many of these biographics
videos I've done are people getting shot
like you know legs out 14 times and not
dying and like you know people walking
into rooms with machine guns and opening
fire indiscriminately and just not
killing everyone there which leads to
believe like gangsters are really bad at
shooting people like surprisingly bad
cuz the amount of these videos that I've
done where just at some point in the
script like yeah this guy they walked in
with a machine gun open fire no one died
it's like what are they doing the
shootout was big news in the Press of
the day he wasn't quite on the level of
a St Valentine's Day Massacre sure but
it was considered to be up there there
was a lot of pressure to end the war so
talk of a truce emerg in the days that
followed Cole sort of trusted only
Madden more than the others which was a
mistake since Madden totally set him up
for short SM to gun him down in broad
daylight on February 8th 1932 Cole
entered a pharmacy to use the telephone
he was immediately following sa Hitman
who pulled out a Tomy gon and gunned him
down with his final Challenger dealt
with Dutch Schultz could now Proclaim
himself the Undisputed a baron of New
York just in time for the end of
prohibition the legal
Wes prohibition was out and with legal
alcohol once again filling the glasses
of happy barflies throughout the country
the need for speak eases and bootleg
Hooch dwindle this meant that men like
Dutch Schultz needed to find new avenues
of Revenue to replace the Lost Golden
Goose well for Dutch this meant using
his considerable resources and criminal
influence to expand into various rackets
like extor a running numbers and
controlling the unions but whenever
someone gains territory in a situation
like this there's usually someone else
who's losing it and they're bound to be
onhappy because there's a lot of money
at stake once again Dutch made some
enemies especially among the black gangs
of Harlem but none of them really posed
a serious threat to him like Colin
Diamond had in fact by this point
Schultz's gang had gotten so powerful
who was the only outfit left in New York
that could rival the Italian mafia in
scope of its operations in fact when
talking about this period people often
mention the big six which refers to the
five MAF families and the Schultz gang
just as an idea of how important he was
in regards to his um criminal influence
and reach although rival outfits did not
pose much of a threat to do he still had
to contend with as all bosses do
internal problems one of his top
lieutenants a guy named Jules Martin who
acted as the front for many of Schultz's
businesses was caught skimming off the
top everyone knew what the end result
would be but as it so happened Schultz's
lawyer Dixie Davis was there to witness
the scene and would describe it in a
tell all book he would write and I quote
Dutch schz was ugly he'd been drinking
and suddenly he had his gun out the
Dutchman wore his pistol under his vest
tucked inside his pants right against
his belly one jerk at his vest and he
had it in his hand all in the same quick
motion he swung it up stuck it in Jules
Martin's mouth and pulled the trigger it
was a simple and undramatic as that one
quick motion of the hand the Dutchman
did that murder just as casually as if
he was picking his teeth but neither
rival gangs nor disloyal employees were
Schultz's biggest headache instead
that's what the form of New York
prosecutor Thomas Dewey a man who Rose
through the the legal system by
declaring war on organized crime and
actually meaning it and doing something
about it the biggest whale he would land
was sending Lucky Luciano to prison for
30 to 50 years before that he set his
sights on Dutch Schultz Dewey's Crusade
against the Dutchman began in the early
30s while prohibition was still in
effect at first it looked like Dutch
would beat the rra but in 1933 Dewey
managed to send another notorious
Bootlegger waxy Gordon to prison for 10
years shortz was getting nervous but
Against All Odds man managed to get
acquitted in his first two trials both
for various counts related to tax
evasion yep it's always tax evasion they
got Al Capone they'll get you too pay
your taxes folks dwey however refused to
surrender once he was made special
prosecutor in 1935 he intended to indict
Schultz again and bring him before a
special grand jury for Dutch the
solution to his problems became obvious
shoot Dewey in the
face Mayhem at the Chop
House for that point the commission had
been formed a special Mafia commit
consisting of the most powerful criminal
outfits in the country which Tred to
govern in a somewhat egalitarian manner
in essence all the gangs decid to join
together and be like hey let's just
commit more crimes let's not fight
because fighting doesn't earn money
crimes make us money and what they're do
instead of fighting is just work out how
to know best work together so although
the commission was a mafia organization
several prominant Jewish Mobsters were
closely associated with it Schultz was
one of these Jewish Associates so when
he decided to offer Dewey he went to the
commission first to request permission
to shoot him in the face he received a
resounding no as the others argued that
assassinating such a high-profile Target
like Dewey Thomas would bring down a
massive law enforcement Crackdown on
every single one of them as you might
imagine do Schultz was not the kind of
guy who took rejection well he basically
said screw you I'm going to shoot him in
the face anyway this present of the
commission with its first serious issue
Schulz wasn't just some schmuck off the
street but he openly ignored their
decision and presented a danger to every
single one of their operations there was
only one answer that to kill Dutch
before he killed dwey once the decision
was made to off Dutch it didn't take
long to materialize on October 23rd 1935
the Dutchman was in Newark New Jersey
having a private dinner with three
Associates at the palace Chop House the
men selected to do the deed were Charles
Workman and Mendy weit two Hitman with
murder Incorporated they simply entered
the restaurant and open fire
indiscriminately they hit all the men at
the table multiple times but Dutch
wasn't among them having quite
fortunately just gone to the bathroom to
relieve himself Workman not wanting to
leave the job unfinished entered the
men's room and hit schs only once which
was enough to get the job done oddly
enough none of the four men died inside
the restaurant they were all taken to
the hospital alive and well then started
dropping one by one schz himself
lingered for an entire day drifting in
and out of Consciousness the police did
try to question him about what had gone
on but he only delivered these strange
nonsensical Garden Path ramblings which
oddly enough became popular enough that
writer William S burrow later using to
write a screenplay titled quite
fittingly the last words of Dutch
Schultz and so the Dutchman was dead his
criminal Empire was broken up piece by
piece and divided among the commission
and guess all that's left now is to find
his buried treasure that's right Schultz
left down a very unusual Legacy more
befitting a pirate than a mobster for 90
years there's been talk that Dutch had
hid a large Fortune somewhere in the CAT
scales mountains in the form of gold
jewels and barabond in a waterproof safe
some s to say a big steel box just in
case he ever had to go on the Run since
then treasure Hunters have been on the
lookout trying to interpret Schultz's
Last Words as Clues to his buried booty
as if he were the Sphinx or something
like that so far no luck but who knows
maybe someone somewhere will find the
Lost Dutchman's Gold and thus the legacy
of Dutch schz continues at least in some
way or form so I hope everybody out
there found this video to be
entertaining educational and informative
I once again apologize for my voice I'm
going to go straight to bed after this
drink some hot lemon and water and Hope
hopefully sweat out this cold I'll try
my best if you did enjoy the video you
can go find links to the author's
socials below links to my socials why
down there clicking on things you can
like the video comment feedback
suggestions all that good stuff
subscribe for more content like this and
as I always like to say at the end of
each video I present go out there and
have the day that you deserve cheers